hey guys i'm ryan right hey I'm light am
iron so we're gonna check out the actual
super well I got the wrong trailer
before we're gonna watch the actual
super bowl trailer for tomorrow land
Tomorrowland is one of my most
anticipated movies of the year the
trailers have not shown us much at all
like they're really done and surely it
hasn't seen any footage of this
whatsoever so I thought it'd be great to
bring her on check this out hey love
Disney
where there's a place
where nothing was impossible where you
build whatever you're crazy enough to
imagine a place where you could actually
change the world hmm you want to go
tomorrow yes please i want to go yeah
yes leave and it's an imax job dad imax
in that visual aspect it's gonna be
great man present buying in your in this
magic lamp yeah yeah some special pin or
something like that the opening line of
this trailer is what if there is a place
where nothing was impossible ever that
before in movies but this movie seems
like it's really taking the imagination
to the next step yeah like I got this
director who did the incredibles and
ratatouille and he added a lots of the
Mission Impossible series if there's one
director who's going to be able to
provide an imagination for a live-action
film that's about nothing being
impossible you're gonna want a director
as creative as the guy who did the
incredibles you know this is like a
movie I would make you and make I would
make this movie you think so yeah
because I believe everything is possible
are ready do you believe that a penis
can attach itself start talking if you
put enough attention to something I
believe I believe in magic um okay I
like the image George Clooney is kind of
giving off in this because I'd like just
cool guy George Clooney you know he's
someone who seems to like an inventor or
a director of something you know cool
role for him yeah it's cool to see him
taking on a new role he's even got like
the gray facial hair and stuff so he's
like been around for quite some time
he's distinguished yes Fox oh yeah he
really is hey George like Narnia and
space it is kind of like Narnia and
space or wherever they are right over
there they showed Hugh Laurie in there
for a second from house and that guy's a
great actor you know he's great playing
an [ __ ] Hopi channels his assholeness
in this and I don't want to be typecast
let it be cool team as an [ __ ] in
this imagination world Tom saying or a
really nice guy oh sure his death or a
detached penis that gone no maybe a dick
hello my dream okay Ryan I mean I guess
it is in space because he does say
buckle up and
any strap song and flies away what's
cool about it is none of the trailers
are telling you exactly what the story
exactly it's so like broad they're
showing you the tone and your
imagination yeah itz you you know like
are teasing me yeah they make you one
more so in just fizzle not the state how
does George Clooney save the world I
need you know cuz I want to change the
world and they're showing George Clooney
more in this trailer but actresses who
saw brittany robertson she's uh she's
really good actress beautiful to look at
I once knew her in real life for like a
couple days anyway she's hot yeah she's
really hot yeah she does good things for
men in terms of her track well she's
just a beautiful goddess yeah yeah so
I'm saying she makes men feel good
before they go to sleep at night and
they you know how well she helps hence
she's an amazing woman she feels she
makes everyone feel good around here
that's true too i'm just saying
especially for guys who are alone in bed
at night she's not a bad person to look
at is all I'm saying um yeah I'm not
disagreeing kids you know what I'm
talking about she's a nice she's a nice
girl she's a great actress yeah she says
whatever you want her to say wouldn't
you think of yeah the trailer was also
thank you for telling me this actual one
was out if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects and
shalina has a channel to color my energy
project director of an actual awesome
event I'm going to be performing the sub
n music you guys have never seen we do
like most serious music side you're
gonna get deep I'm really excited to get
some tears in there yeah I'm gonna cry
you with me I'm gonna cry I get very
emotional I hope you feel like it's so
beautiful that's awesome and I hope that
happens yeah well I promise you yeah so
check that out you go to trial see what
it's all about my Internet's down
because AT&T u-verse is a dick
they're the worst internet company ever
they have [ __ ] me over several times
and if you guys are watching you can go
[ __ ] yourself and I hope your company
burns down one day I'm running cables
time warner cable here is awesome we go
to facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts where you can earn yourself a
shout out by saying something
interesting like Tomorrowland is full of
many mermaids and pleasure many merman
I'm sure if anything is possible that is
a possibility I mean mermaids and mermen
can they meet because they don't have
penises well how do they reproduce if
they don't meet I don't know they just
lay an egg where would it come out their
mouth